[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente esto es lo que veremos hoy
apenas un día después de asumir como
presidente del perú pedro castillo
enfrentó su primera crisis el maestro de
izquierda nombró a guido bellido como
primer ministro se trata de un
izquierdista radical que considera que
en cuba hay democracia que sendero
luminoso no es un grupo terrorista y
aquí en asociaciones lgtb más consideran
homófobo lo que ya despertó el rechazo
del poderoso congreso peruano en texas
el gobernador firmó una polémica ley en
contra de los latinos supuestamente para
proteger a los texanos del cob y 19 una
medida irónica ya que su estado ha sido
desde el inicio de la pandemia
uno de los más laxos en cuanto a las
restricciones contra el coronavirus de
hecho levantó en marzo el uso
obligatorio de los tapabocas
y en chile el ministerio de obras
públicas ordenó el traslado de un altar
que se conoce como animita ubicado en
una de las principales vías del país se
trata de un lugar lleno de ofrendas como
culto a quienes fallecieron en trágicas
circunstancias y aunque la sociedad
chilena le tiene un especial respeto
nuestra corresponsal en santiago
acompañó el traslado de la niña bonita'
y vamos de inmediato a perú con la
imagen de la semana pedro castillo juró
como presidente poniendo fin a semanas
de incertidumbre generados por la demora
en la entrega de los resultados
oficiales de las elecciones
presidenciales del 6 de junio pero aún
es incierto si esto significa el fin de
la inestabilidad en el país pues el
nombramiento de su gabinete genera
polémica y su primer ministro tiene un
mes para conquistar el voto de confianza
del congreso castillo derrotó por muy
pocos votos a la hija del ex presidente
alberto fujimori quien fue condenado por
delitos de lesa humanidad el maestro de
izquierda llegó hasta hace muy poco a la
escena política prometiendo cambios en
el sistema
juro por los pueblos del perú por un
país sin corrupción y por una nueva
constitución
por fin perú tiene un nuevo presidente
pedro castillo tomó posesión de su cargo
el miércoles en lima luego de que el
jurado nacional de elecciones desestimar
a apenas una semana tras las denuncias
del fraude de keiko fujimori es la
primera vez que nuestro país será
gobernado por un campesino una persona
que pertenece como muchos de los
peruanos a los sectores oprimidos por
tantos siglos también es la primera vez
que un partido político formado en el
interior del país gana las elecciones
democráticamente
el profesor de izquierda se convierte
así en el quinto presidente del perú en
cinco años y su margen de gobernabilidad
es incierto ya que no cuenta con la
mayoría en el congreso un congreso muy
poderoso que destituyó al ex presidente
pedro pablo kuczynski declaró la
incapacidad mental del exmandatario
martín vizcarra y declaró la vacancia
luego de que asumiera brevemente manuel
merino y castillo tiene bastantes
detractores durante la campaña fue
acusado de querer llevar el modelo
económico de venezuela perú algo que él
negó en varias oportunidades
lamentablemente durante la campaña
electoral se ha tratado y asustar a la
población con el cuento que queríamos
expropiar los ahorros las casas los
automóviles las fábricas y otros bienes
de propiedad de los ciudadanos lo que es
totalmente falso
pero sus decisiones ya están impactando
los mercados
-pedro frank el hombre que había calmado
a empresarios al asegurarles que perú no
les expropiaría sus compañías renunció a
ser el ministro de economía y el dólar
rompió su valor histórico tras el
nombramiento de guido bellido como
primer ministro quien es conocido por su
simpatía con la extrema izquierda y es
investigado por presunta apología al
terrorismo tras manifestar en redes
sociales su apoyo al grupo sendero
luminoso
entretanto algunos sectores cuestionan
que sólo dos mujeres hagan parte de su
gabinete
vamos a eeuu el gobernador de texas en
republicano greg abbott firmó una orden
ejecutiva que obliga al departamento de
salud pública estatal a detener
cuestionar y desviar vehículos en los
que se trasladan personas que se vean
como latinos supuestamente para frenar
los contagios de coronavirus la
iniciativa considerada racista por
organizaciones defensoras de los
derechos ya fue rechazada por la
administración federal el fiscal general
de la unión americana american land
amenazó a abbott con buscar todos los
recursos legales para garantizar que
texas no interfiera con las funciones de
la administración baiden veamos más en
el siguiente informe
[Música]
y madres con niños pequeños jóvenes
solos familias enteras decenas de
personas siguen arriesgando su vida en
improvisadas balsas cruzando el río
bravo o río grande para llegar a estados
unidos buscando un futuro mejor
esta familia llora al tocar el suelo de
roma en textos
no los detuvo la patrulla fronteriza ni
las reiteradas declaraciones de la
administración bailén de que la frontera
no está abierta
ni tampoco las medidas del gobernador de
texas quien esta semana ordenó a
funcionarios de la guardia nacional
apoyar al departamento de salud pública
a detener interrogar hacer regresar e
incluso tomar custodia de vehículos que
transporten personas que parezcan
latinos
según él la negativa del presidente joe
biden a aplicar la ley no puede
permitirse porque compromete la salud y
seguridad de los tejanos contra el co
bit 19 una medida estricta si se compara
con su decisión de marzo de 2021 de
levantar la orden de usar mascarillas
mucho antes de la recomendación de los
centros para el control de enfermedades
del país para esa fecha sólo se había
vacunado el 8% de la población del
estado y cerca del 50 por ciento de los
fallecimientos eran personas de origen
hispano organizaciones defensoras de los
derechos consideran la medida como
racista esta es una clara militarización
de texas en contra de individuos niños y
familias por un gobernador que está
fuera de control y que cree tener poder
unilateral para hacer lo que quiera y
violar los derechos civiles de la gente
solamente por su apariencia o por
sospecha
barkos en julio pasado abbott también
anunció que texas construirá su propio
muro fronterizo
y si vamos con más información de eeuu
esta semana comenzó en el congreso la
investigación del asalto al capitolio
del 6 de enero por parte de seguidores
del ex presidente de donald trump en el
que murieron 5 personas y al menos 140
policías resultaron heridos precisamente
en la primera sesión cuatro policías se
entregaron su testimonio los agentes
coincidieron en la necesidad de llegar a
la cabeza detrás del asalto en alusiones
claras al ex presidente trans notaba que
me faltaba el oxígeno me recuerdo
diciéndome a mí mismo así es cómo voy a
morir defendiendo esta entrada
vamos a méxico los ciudadanos participan
en una polémica consulta popular con la
pregunta estás de acuerdo o no en que se
lleven a cabo las acciones pertinentes
con apego al marco constitucional y
legal para emprender un proceso de
esclarecimiento de las decisiones
políticas tomadas en los años pasados
por los actores políticos encaminados a
garantizar la justicia y los derechos de
las posibles víctimas
fue convocada por el presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador y es conocida como
la consulta para juzgar a los
expresidentes una consulta que sin
embargo para algunos generan más
preguntas que respuestas ya que para que
sus resultados sea vinculante debía
participar al menos el 40 por ciento de
las personas inscritas en el padrón
electoral nuestro corresponsal mario'
carbonell recogió opiniones en la ciudad
de mexico para que la gente tenga la
posibilidad de pues de opinar en este
respecto se haga conciencia de que pues
la corrupción ya no puede ser algo del
día a día pues es una tontería porque
ningún presidente va a aceptar que robo
a méxico o que lo saqueo y mucho menos
lo va a regresar entonces es como que
una pérdida de tiempo y vamos a hablar
de las animitas de chile son una serie
de obras de arte popular que se erigen
en las vías del país austral como un
recuerdo de los que se fueron trágicas o
tempranamente las animitas nacieron en
chile en las apachetas es decir en las
piedras acumuladas por los indígenas con
él
de invocar protección sagrada en los
caminos y para recordar a los fallecidos
recientemente muchos han sido
trasladados pero como se trata de
santuarios populares muy respetados para
hacerlo se debe pedir autorización a los
familiares y hacerlo de forma muy
cuidadosa nuestra corresponsal en chile
patricia luna nos cuenta la historia del
traslado de una de las animitas más
populares la de astrid
todo un santuario en medio de una de las
principales carreteras que conectan la
capital chilena santiago con la playa
miles de ositos de peluche se han
acumulado durante años en esta limita
conocida como astrid la niña hermosa
aquí falleció la joven en un accidente
de moto en 1998 y desde entonces se ha
convertido en una leyenda cuya fama no
cesa camila viene a agradecer a astrid
bueno esto es un tema personal y salió
todo bien de subir muchas son muchas
emociones junta un poquillo en el
estómago es un tema de alegría porque
uno ya se siente aliviada y aparte que
que cumplió lo que uno le pidió esta
niñita que registra más de 100 visitas
al día es una de las muchas que se han
trasladado en los últimos meses a un
lugar con las pesos más seguros como
parte de un plan de mejorar las
carreteras hay mucha gente que usa yo al
menos me pregunto
si ella igual se va a molestar porque ha
gastado toda su vida de entre comillas
la empresa a cargo de la obra realizó
todos los trámites junto a un sacerdote
que bendijo cada acto está acompañando
la familia en todo este proceso ya los
trabajadores también porque los
trabajadores
de la obra en esto con mucho respeto
así que a ellos también se le hacen
bendiciones y toda una comunicación la
nueva ubicación del memorial de astrid
es sin duda mucho más segura pero
también le falta algo del carácter y la
emoción que tenía la antigua es quizá
por eso que muchas personas continúan
yendo al viejo emplazamiento para rezar
ante su espíritu
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américas hoy natalia cabrera y
pueden seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas en la
producción estuvo giovanni agudelo
recuerden que pueden ver este y otros
programas en france24 punto com
[Música]